you know you're on spring break in
Australia and the condom broke and you
have to go get the morning after pill
for a girl that you don't even know and
uh they don't even let you get it
without the girl in Australia like you
have to and then I didn't know and then
so I had to have my friend who wasn't
the girl I had sex with come and pretend
that it was her uh which was weird did
you watch her take it or you took her
word for it I had to take her word for
it cuz we had to leave I think she did I
haven't gotten a phone call did you did
you check in to make sure she did like
you do that I thought that was like
really be really rude it would be rude
but you still want to know yeah but I I
I I don't want to dehumanize and you
know well literally that's what you're
doing you're DEH that is true that is
I'm doing not dehumanized a fully
spawned human there you go there you go